aujourd'hui c'est un grand jour puisque
aujourd'hui c'est l'anniversaire de mon
ami jean michel maire
[Applaudissements]
jean-michel je sais vous aviez deux
passions et xavier deux passions dans la
vie vous aviez de rêve des nouveaux
cheveux et une trottinette je sais que
vous voulez ça pour leur anniversaire
les cheveux c'est fait eh bien regardez
j'ai allier les deux c'est pour vous
regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un cadeau c'est vraiment mon cadeau mais
je vais partir et les cheveux c'est le
cadeau de de cyril c'est l'autre cadeau
de baba je voulais mais la mêlée vous
partirez avec c'est votre anniversaire
tvo le cadeau est muet
or voilà mon agent me c'est vraiment
pour toi ses pairs mais j'ai 59
aujourd'hui et j'ai réalisé aujourd'hui
quand j'ai commencé j'avais 48 et joué
59 aujourd'hui c'est celle où je
remercie cyril pour la trottinette
évidemment et pour cet incroyable et
belle aventure que je vis depuis 11 ans
maintenant
ce qui est incroyable eh beh entrée
janvier est plus due à des comme ça
c'est la terre se baladent autres bravo
mon agent me alors bien sûr il ya un
autre gars sont qu'un autre garçon qui a
un petit message pour vous regardez
c'est prenez ma devise c'est un petit
message
aujourd'hui j'apprends que c'est
l'anniversaire de mon meilleur ennemi
jean michel maire alors tu vois je
passais outre tout tout et outrages
envers moi bon anniversaire un peu de me
casser les couilles vient sur le plateau
et ciao milou rajeunie et donc gens me
voient là il vous a dit bon anniversaire
alors jean mi il ya le risque est là
c'est aussi votre cadeau ce que je sais
que vous l'adorez bah je sais pas c'est
les ravi de te font cadeau mais moi
c'est de la mort c'est à dire votre
cadeau c'est la présence de l'autre
cadeau pour jean michel et moi j'ai fait
un texte
vous allez faire texte mais oui j'ai
fait un texte vous voulez peut-être des
lunettes pour le lien mais j'ai pas pris
ce débat là je vais faire sans jean bie
derrière la façade du goût ja j'ai cru
longtemps qu'il n'y avait rien ces mois
par un groupe b à part un gros ici bon
bah c'est bon mais très vite j'ai
découvert un être sensible brillant
fidèles attentionné et cultivé autour de
qualité qu'ils pouvaient que nous
rapprocher puisque j'ai les mêmes sauf
un gros zizis haut et devenu mon ami
bonne anniversaire c'est vous qui avez
créé ça bien sûr c'est vraiment de la
merde
c'est beau ça vient du mercy benjamines
hulot c'est pas nul pas fait oublier les
allées mur à mon père si benjamin